Bonjour à tous, ici Alexis De
Lancer, très très très heureux
de vous retrouver pour cette
discussion en direct euh sur
fond de campagne électorale
notre dernière discussion en
direct de la de cette campagne
on en on est quoi au jour
trente-quatre le vote approche
à grands pas au terme de cette
campagne atypique a bien des
égards vous le savez pour
toutes sortes de raisons euh
avant de commencer je vous
rappelle que cette période
qu'on passe ensemble ben elle
vous est consacrée en grande
partie et vous en des artisans
dans la mesure où on attend vos
questions. On attend euh vos
propositions de de de si on
veut de discussions qu'on va
avoir avec nos invités. La
parole est donc à vous. Hésitez
pas à le faire. On a une bonne
demi-heure ensemble. On a de
quoi meubler cette
demi-heure-là sans aucun doute
avant de commencer. Je rappelle
aussi quelques détails
concernant la soirée électorale
que tous les artisans de
l'information à Radio-Canada
sont en train de préparer en ce
moment. J'en ai croisé
quelques-uns. Soirée électorale
sur toutes nos plateformes.
Lundi prochain dès dix-sept 55
sur ICI RDI, Radio-Canada point
CA sur Facebook et sur YouTube,
partout où Radio-Canada,
information est présent, 9
heures sur ICI Première, 19h30
sur ICI Télé et Tou point TV.
Bref, ça va être dur à manquer.
Et le moment est venu de
souhaiter la bienvenue à nos
panélistes, à mes
collaborateurs du jour, à mes
chers collègues et analystes,
Daniel Thibeault qu'on retrouve
à Ottawa. Salut Daniel Salut
bien. Et qui dans ces studios
des coulisses du Bouvoir,
Daniel, animateur des coulisses
du pouvoir et analyste sur
biais sur plusieurs de nos euh
plateformes observateurs
aguerris la scène politique
fédérale tout comme Madeleine
Blais-Morin, chef de bureau
parlementaire toujours un
plaisir de te retrouver
Madeleine . Merci, bonjour tout
le monde. Alors, avant de
commencer euh bien entendu là,
faut faut garder en tête qu'il
y a il y a il y a un côté bilan
à notre discussion euh c'est un
on c'est pas tout à fait fini,
c'est le vrai véritablement le
sprint final qui s'amorce. En
ce moment tout le monde est
dans le sud de l'Ontario, ça
nous indique ou presque alors
ça nous indique à quel point
euh les endroits où ça peut se
jouer, mais j'aimerais vous
entendre tour à tour vos
réflexions instinctives sur
cette campagne qui nous a en
tout cas moi m'a surpris à
certains égards est-ce que vous
attendiez Madeleine à ce type
de campagne à la tournure que
ça a pris là? Non pas vraiment
parce qu'au début de la
campagne électorale on se
demandait si Justin Trudeau
obtiendrait oui ou non une
majorité et après quelques
jours on s'est dit oh là là
Justin Trudeau est en train de
se battre pour conserver le
pouvoir. Donc l'hypoth de
départ, la question de départ
avait complètement changé et à
mon avis Alexis euh un
commentateur qui dans une
prochaine élection dirait
vingt-quatre h48 heures après
le déclenchement d'une élection
on en parle plus de du
déclenchement je pense que il y
penserait euh avant de
prononcer cette phrase-là parce
qu'elle ne s'est pas avérée
cette cette vérité-là qu'on
qu'on énonçait comme une vérité
là le fait qu'on on parle plus
du déclenchement des élections
euh après euh quelques jour
cette fois-ci ça a été
l'exception qui a confirmé la
règle on en a parlé pendant des
jours de cette décision de
Justin Trudeau de déclencher
les élections en pleine
pandémie euh a surpris un peu
les libéraux du moins euh parce
qu'il a grimpé dans les
sondages au début de la
campagne puis après bon la
course a été plus difficile
pour lui et là on est presque à
la ligne d'arrivée pis on se
demande un peu qui va
l'emporter ce qui rend euh la
soirée électorale très
intéressante. Ouais une soirée
qui risque d'être longues avec
en plus le vote par
correspondance qui est assez
volumineux. On compte tout ça à
partir du lendemain à la
mitaine. Wow! Euh il va y avoir
des luttes sérieux. On y
revient dans quelques instants.
Les questions sont nombreuses.
On on complète ce tour de table
Daniel sur les impressions à ce
stade-ci de la campagne par
rapport à ce qu'on a
entrevoyait au tout départ.
J'aimerais vous entendre
là-dessus. Ouais on le savait
du côté des libéraux que ce
serait euh ce ça se ferait à
l'arraché, que ce serait pas
une victoire simple si il y
avait victoire que ce serait
chirurgical qu'on irait
chercher des sièges des petits
des des petits blocs de sièges
un peu partout à travers le
pays. C'est comme ça qu'on
l'avait imaginé la campagne.
Madeleine disait tout à l'heure
euh ce ce que l'on appelle dans
le jargon le process story là
euh cette capacité pour un
parti de dire bon voici on
déclenche l'élection, on en
parle pendant 36, 48 heures pis
après ça c'est terminé. C'est
vrai que les libéraux étaient
convaincus que ça allait passer
ça et c'est comme si on n'avait
pas pensé à une justification
adéquate du côté du euh du camp
libéral avant de déclencher.
C'est ce qui fait que ça a
traîné dans dans dans euh dans
la sphère publique pendant euh
plusieurs plusieurs jours,
plusieurs semaines à certains
égards c'est encore soulevé
aujourd'hui euh par les euh par
les conservateurs et les
néo-démocrates alors on on on a
eu l'air d'être pris de court
dans le cadre d'une élection
qu'on avait qu'ils avaient
eux-mêmes déclenché du côté
libéral. Surprise aussi
effectivement euh et je
reviendrai pas sur ce que
disait Madeleine mais euh dans
le cas dans le camp
conservateur euh on a eu
l'impression que on avait
réussi à faire. Ouais.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient
anticipé pour faire découvrir
le chef pour peut-être aller
faire des gains. Pis là ben là
évidemment on vient à la case
départ là. Je vous ferai pas de
surprise si je vous dis que
cette fin de semaine aux
coulisses on va entre autres
parler du gouvernement qui
risque d'être de nouveau
minoritaire. C'est le scénario
que tout le monde envisage ou à
peu près. Euh et donc ça va
soulever la question. Pourquoi
exactement on a tenu cet
exercice-là si on revient
exactement avec ce que l'on
avait comme parlement avant de
commencer. Euh en tout cas il y
en a la soulever cette
question-là, ça va être
intéressant de voir ce qui euh
ce qu'on votera de l'avant
comme réponses. Oui et et ce
que ça va donner comme résultat
au terme du processus euh mais
avant ça il va avoir des luttes
très serrées. Question qui nous
est posée ici par Matteo. Euh
merci Matéo pour cette
question. Très simple, mais on
est vraiment au coeur euh des
des des enjeux importants à ce
stade-ci. À quels endroits
risquent-ils d'y avoir des
courses très très très serrées.
Madeleine ça se joue où cette
élection? Euh comme Daniel
c'est chirurgical, ça se joue à
plusieurs endroits et pas
nécessairement dans un gros
bloc. C'est pas par exemple
uniquement dans la banlieue de
Toronto qu'on dit tellement
cruciale. Les libéraux qui
voulaient obtenir une majorité
même s'ils ne le disaient pas
espéraient faire des gains par
exemple. Euh Beauport Limoilou.
Ça c'est un siège qui est
détenu par le Bloc québécois.
Euh c'est dans la grande région
de Québec. Les libéraux
pensaient peut-être pouvoir
l'emporter. Entre autres parce
c'était extrêmement serré la
dernière fois. Même chose pour
Trois-Rivières. Encore une fois
vous voyez c'est une une lutte
qui se jouait entre autre avec
le bloc qui détenait le siège
mais là entre en scène le parti
conservateur. Donc là on va
parler d'une lutte à trois très
très très serrées. C'est deux
exemples. Donc pas
nécessairement des
circonscriptions qui sont
collées l'une sur l'autre. Je
pense à la Gaspésie. Mais là la
Gaspésie ce sont les libéraux
qui la détiennent alors que les
blocistes veulent l'arracher.
Donc c'est pas la lutte va pas
toujours dans le même sens là.
Parfois euh les libéraux
essayent d'arracher des sièges,
parfois c'est le Bloc
Québécois. Là on parle du
Québec ailleurs au pays il va y
avoir des cours séries quand
même dans la grande région de
Toronto. Il y a des courses
qu'on va surveiller en
Colombie-Britannique parce que
là il y a une dynamique à trois
qui s'opère extrêmement
difficile de prévoir ce qui va
se qui va se passer en
Colombie-Britannique. Alors
raison de plus pour penser
qu'on va se coucher très tard
lundi soir parce que là le NV
et fort, les libéraux s'en
tirent bien et le parti
conservateur est très
concurrentiel. Donc ça fait des
dynamiques qui sont très très
difficiles de prévoir. Daniel
quand on euh juste avant le
déclenchement de l'élection je
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'asseoir
avec un stratège libéral on a
fait on a fait le tour de
toutes les provinces du pays,
les 338 circonscriptions. Ça se
faisait par bloc de 2 ou 3
sièges. On va en gagner un ici,
on va en perdre un là au
Québec. On va peut-être aller
en chercher trois ou quatre. Ce
calcul-là il a cessé de tenir,
je vous dirais à mi-chemin dans
la et là aujourd'hui on regarde
un peu où est-ce qu'on peut
sauver les meubles
permettez-moi l'expression. Euh
ce que vous devriez surveiller
euh le soir euh lundi soir,
Mathéo euh je pense qu'en
Atlantique les choses risquent
d'être assez neutres euh du
côté du Québec les libéraux
semblent faire bonne figure,
toute chose étant relative.
regardez les courses en
Ontario, la dernière fois en
2019, c'était là que le Parti
Libéral avait fait le plein de
sièges. À la toute dernière
minute, c'était ça qui leur
avait donné le gouvernement
minoritaire. Est-ce que on va
être capable de maintenir ces
acquis-là euh quelqu'un me dit
cette semaine on a déjà euh on
on est allé chercher tout ce
qu'on pouvait aller chercher en
Ontario. Alors des gains de ce
côté-là c'est peut-être un peu
plus compliqué pis les
conservateurs sont compétitifs.
Il y a des petites, il y a de
petites fenêtres qui se sont
ouvertes. Pensez à l'Alberta,
il risque d'y avoir quelques
courses intéressantes là-bas et
les libéraux pourraient aller
rafler un ou deux sièges aux
conservateurs. La dynamique
entre les libéraux fédéraux,
monsieur Kenny euh depuis 48 h
change la donne de ce côté-là
pis évidemment on le dit à à
chaque élection mais j'ai
l'impression que cette fois-ci
c'est plus vrai que jamais. Ça
va se passer en
Colombie-Britannique, on va
attendre de voir comment ça se
déroule là-bas parce que les
courses à trois c'est très très
serré. Et on parlait du vote
par correspondance. Les 7 des
10 circonscriptions où on a
demandé le plus de bulletins de
vote par correspondance. Elles
sont en Colombie-Britannique.
Ah bon? Alors s'il faut qu'on
attende le résultat de course
serrée où il y a dans certains
cas plusieurs milliers de
bulletins de vote par
correspondance qui ont été
envoy dans certaines
circonscriptions clés. Ouais.
Ça peut vouloir dire qu'on va
les attendre encore quelques
jours ces résultats-là. Euh ça
ça va rendre la dynamique, ça
va rendre la course
intéressante lundi soir. Ben
dans, dans, dans vos réponses,
vous avez euh Madeleine et
Daniel un peu préparé le
terrain euh pour répondre aux
autres questions que j'ai ici à
vous soumettre euh allons-y
avec la première ici que j'ai
sous les yeux. Euh vous parliez
de ces luttes à trois. Euh
c'était à prévoir dans le
contexte où où on est en ce
moment, mais quand même, c'est
assez, c'est particulier là. Et
et je rajoute ici, si on jette
un un coup d'oeil euh aux
travaux ou aux analyses plutôt
de Philippe Gilles Fournier euh
dans son système d'agrégation
de moyenne de sondage. On est à
32% des pour les libéraux, 31,7
pour les conservateurs. Euh
c'est dans ce contexte-là que
Justin Trudeau cette semaine a
sorti la carte du vote
stratégique. Question ici,
question ici de Juan. Euh
prénommé Juan, merci beaucoup
pour votre question. Alors qui
va comme suit depuis une
semaine? On entend Justin
Trudeau parler de votre
stratégique. Est-ce que ça
fonctionne vraiment cette
tactique nous demande Juan
Madeleine si les libéraux
sortent la carte, chaque fois
c'est parce qu'ils pensent que
ça fonctionne. C'est il y a un
libéral qui me disait on va pas
changer une recette qui
fonctionne. Et c'est toujours
le même prétexte, c'est de dire
on veut essayer de bloquer la
route aux conservateurs. Donc
on essaie chez les libéraux de
grappiller des sièges chez les
néo-démocrates sachant que ce
sont des votes dits
progressistes. Donc on on c'est
une stratégie qui a été
utilisée là de mémoire. Ça fait
une quinzaine d'années que je
couvre la politique fédérale.
Ça a été utilisé à chaque
élection peut-être à
l'exception de 2011, la Société
d'exception de la vague orange
les libéraux s'ils avaient
utilisé cette carte-là à ce
moment-là peut-être que ça
aurait eu un effet contraire
là, peut-être qu'ils auraient
poussé des votes libéraux vers
le le NPD. Mais généralement ça
s'utilise et il y a un
néo-démocrate, un ancien
stratège en fait néo-démocrate
Carl Bélanger qui me disait
cette semaine à son avis plus
cette stratégie-là est utilisée
tôt dans la campagne, plus ça
démontre le niveau de nervosité
chez les libéraux. là c'est euh
ben c'est relativement normal
je dirais là à quelques jours
du vote on a entendu Justin
Trudeau évoquer cette cette
appel au vote progressiste
depuis quelques jours déjà.
Donc euh on est dans la dans
l'ordre des choses il y a rien
de surprenant c'est comme ça
que ça se passe mais je voyais
des conservateurs faire un peu
la même chose aujourd'hui ou
des des un journal de tendances
conservatrices le son disant si
vous votez pour Maxime Bernier
vous allez peut-être vous
retrouver avec Justin Trudeau
au pouvoir que si le vote du
Parti Conservateur à la droite
s'érode au profit de Maxime
Bernier, mais peut-être que ça
va avantager le parti
conservateur donc ça se joue de
des deux côtés du spectre sur
votre stratégique. Ah moi je
trouve ça très intéressant cet
aspect-là des choses ayant
ayant vécu et travaillé en
Alberta pendant un certain
temps et là je vois que les
ouais. Les troupes de Maxime
Bernier et du Parti Populaire
Conservateur sur les réseaux
sociaux au Décrypteur c'est ce
qu'on a dénoté depuis le début
de la campagne. Ceux qui sont
dans les top X du jour en
Twitter le plus souvent depuis
le début de cette campagne
c'est ce c'est ce parti, cette
organisation qui a une
stratégie web assez
particulière parle de vagues
mauves évidemment on est loin
du compte euh à ce stade-ci
c'est ce qu'on peut dire mais
Daniel poursuivons et terminons
concluons sur la question du
vote stratégique écoutez euh il
y a il y a pour que ça
fonctionne et c'est vrai que ça
fonctionne pour les libéraux,
si ça fonctionnait pas ils
l'utiliseraient pas il y a un
sondeur qui me disait la
semaine dernière il y a environ
le tiers des électeurs
néo-démocrates qui sont des
électeurs progressistes qui
sont disposés à changer de camp
s'ils ont l'impression que leur
vote peut faire une une
différence. Donc il y a 33 %
électorale néo-démocrate qui
est susceptible d'écouter le
message des libéraux et de dire
ah ben devant le risque de voir
arriver au pouvoir un
gouvernement conservateur je
vais aller camper mon vote du
côté rouge. Pour que ça
fonctionne évidemment faut que
l'appel soit fait, faut qu'il
soit crédible et pour qu'il
soit crédible il faut qu'il y
ait une menace. Et là on est
dans des espèces de tempêtes
parfaites parce que il y a
effectivement on le voit dans
les sondages, une possibilité
bien réelle qui a une minorité
euh une minorité d'un côté
comme de l'autre. Donc cette
carte-là pour le gouvernement
pour pour le le parti de
monsieur Trudeau euh elle est
jouable et elle pourrait être
efficace Euh par ailleurs euh
ce serait intéressant de voir
euh les les les troubles de
Maxime Bernier vous en parliez
tout à l'heure euh il y a un
stratège conservateur qui me
disait hier on pense qu'il y a
à peu près 75 % des gens qui
sont allés se ranger chez
Maxime Bernier qui viennent de
chez nous. C'est un problème
est-ce que ces gens-là seraient
allés voter? Est-ce que ces
gens-là vont aller voter? Mais
dans certaines dans certaines
régions l'Alberta le Sud-Ouest
ontarien il y a un risque réel
que ça une différence. Pas que
les les les gens de monsieur
Bernier que les candidats du
Parti populaire du Canada euh
aillent chercher un siège parce
que ça c'est c'est relativement
c'est relativement peu probable
mais qui divise suffisamment le
vote comme le disait Madeleine
pour effectivement permettre à
un candidat libéral au
néo-démocrate dans certaines
régions de se peaufiner dans le
milieu. Ça va être intéressant
de la surveiller cette
dynamique-là parce que on est
passé dans les deux chiffres
hein dans certains endroits là
les sondages régionaux pour le
parti populaire. Ça nous ça
donne du dix 11 %. C'est
anecdotique, ce sont de petits
échantillon mais quand même ça
pourrait faire une différence
lundi. Euh il y a des choses
que j'entends et que je vois
souvent depuis un un certain
nombre de jours et je présume
que c'est alimenté par ce qui
s'est passé aux États-Unis
plusieurs personnes euh malgré
les propos rassurants
d'élections au Canada se
s'inquiètent face justement euh
à la montée du vote par
correspondance et à l'impact
que ça peut avoir sur le
processus électorale et tout le
reste question de Vincent qui
fait écho à cette préoccupation
qui je crois est quand même
assez présente dans l'esprit
personnes euh on a probablement
probablement écrit-il pas le on
aura probablement pas le
résultat du vote le soir des
élections en raison du vote
postal comme ce fut le cas aux
États-Unis dit Vincent
risque-t-on de voir ici aussi
des partis ou des acteurs
politiques tenter de remettre
en doute le processus
électorale ou démocratique. Les
chefs concluent-ils, se
sont-ils engagés à reconnaître
le résultat du vote? Ben je
crois pour les principaux chefs
ça va de soi. Mais mais
j'aimerais vous entendre
là-dessus sur ces ces doutes
que ça peut entretenir dans
l'esprit de électorale
Madeleine moi j'ai l'impression
que la remise en question qu'on
a vue aux États-Unis ne se
trans pas ici au Canada parce
que aux États-Unis on avait
Donald Trump le chef d'un parti
le le président sortant qui
contestait pratiquement
lui-même le résultat électorale
on ne voit pas ça ici on ne
voit pas euh commencer à dire
que bon il va douter du
résultat électorale on est loin
loin loin loin loin loin de ce
scénario-là. Alors je pense pas
que ça soit ça fasse partie là
des grandes préoccupations de
de l'électorat ici. On a vu
donc cette montée du Parti
Populaire euh est-ce que dans
ce mouvement-là qui est plus à
droite il pourrait y avoir une
remise en question du système?
Peut-être parce qu'il y a des
partisans là-dedans qui sont un
peu antisystème. On s'entend.
Mais ils forment bon si on on
évalue là dans les sondages
environ 6 % selon la moyenne
des sondage qu'on peut
recueillir jusqu'à maintenant
c'est une force qui est qui
existe mais qui est quand même
pas majeure dans le spectre
politique canadien. Ouais et et
la meilleure façon finalement
de rassurer les gens c'est
d'expliquer comment ça marche,
comment ça fonctionne. On le
rappelle il y a pas de machine
comme aux États-Unis. C'est à
la main que ça se fait. Et euh
ça se fait qu'est-ce qu'on peut
comment on pourrait résumer la
façon de procéder Daniel en ce
qui concerne euh ces euh le
dépouillement de ses votes? Bon
euh il y a peut-être euh
j'ajouterais ce que disait
Madeleine peut-être un élément
qui est particulier aux
États-Unis au-delà de l'appel
de monsieur Trump qui était non
négligeable quand même il y
avait aussi le fait que euh le
système est géré au niveau au
niveau des états donc il y
avait de petites différences
ici et là qui ouvraient des
brèches qui permettaient
peut-être d'imaginer des
contestations ou de soulever
certains problèmes ici au
Canada, le système de vote il
est géré par élections Canada
c'est fait au niveau national
alors le bulletin que vous avez
commandé que vous soyez au
Yukon au Québec ou euh dans
dans au Nouveau-Brunswick c'est
le même bulletin vous arrive de
la même façon quand il revient
chez Élections Canada ce
bulletin-là il est envoyé dans
la circonscription vous
l'enregistrez alors il sera
dans cette circonscription-là
et là je vous parle
d'expérience parce que moi je
l'ai commandé mon petit
bulletin de vote par la poste,
je voulais voir comment ça
fonctionnait pis j'étais
curieux un peu de voir quel
genre de système relativement
efficace je vous dirais après
j'ai reçu le bulletin à la
maison 48 heures après l'avoir
commandé euh on le remplace il
y a une série dans voilà on
remplit, on met le bulletin
dans une petite enveloppe, on
met l'enveloppe dans une
seconde enveloppe, la seconde
enveloppe elle est adressée à
la circonscription elle est
elle elle redirige le bulletin
dans la circonscription où
l'électeur est enregistré et
qu'au fur et à mesure où les
bulletins arrivent, ils sont
renvoyés dans la
circonscription et après la
fermeture des bureaux de
scrutin, on va compter les
votes dans les boîtes et
ensuite on va se mettre à
compter ce qui a été reçu par
correspondance ajouter à cela
le fait qu'on cesse d'accepter
les votes par correspondance au
moment de la fermeture des
bureaux de scrutin lundi soir
donc il y a des votes il y a
des bulletins de vote qui vont
présumément arriver un peu plus
tard dans le courant de la
semaine donc faudra les compter
aussi ceux-là Canada me disait
cette semaine normalement sur
une euh ceux qui sont ceux qui
arrivent plus tard ils ne les
comptent pas si je ceux qui
arrivent ceux qui arrivent
après leurs limites ne seront
pas comptés mais ceux qui
arrivent au moment le jour même
n'arriveront pas immédiatement
dans le bureau de vote. Ils
vont devoir être acheminés au
bureau de vote et être comptés
ensuite. Euh on nous disait que
le on nous disait que le le le
le retour normalement le taux
de retour quand on a des votes
par correspondance à l'étranger
c'est d'environ 15 % jusqu'ici
on pense que le le le taux de
retour fluctue dans les
environs de 50 % on se demande
à quel point ça va monter
davantage il y a pas
d'indications à l'effet que si
il y a un niveau d'impopularité
là euh il y a une il y a un
certain nombre de vérifications
qui doivent être faites hein on
va compter le vote dans la le
vote par correspondance pour
s'assurer que la personne a pas
non aussi voté en personne à ce
moment-là c'est la raison pour
laquelle ça se fait euh au
niveau de la circonscription.
Et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la soirée électorale
risque d'être longue et voire
même se prolonger. En tout cas
le résultat définitif je pense
quà ce stade-ci il faut pas
l'attendre le lundi soir là de
façon euh claire et certaine ça
c'est sûr. Euh le temps file
chers amis. Euh j'aurais tant
aimé pour suivre cette
discussion encore euh pendant
plusieurs minutes. Il nous en
reste cinq à peu près en ce
moment. Il y a une question de
Sophie qui je crois est très
pertinente puisque c'est
vraiment, ça a marqué la
campagne du début à la fin.
Voici la question de Sophie a
parole ensuite Daniel et
Madeleine quel effet va
finalement avoir eu la pandémie
de coviddix-9 sur la campagne.
Madeleine c'est particulier
parce qu'on peut pas le mesurer
encore parce qu'il il vient de
se passer dans la campagne
électorale quelque chose qui a
ramené la gestion de la
pandémie vraiment à
l'avant-plan et c'est la
volte-face de Jason Kenney en
Alberta qui vient embêter par
association Donc à la toute fin
de juste avant que les gens
commencent à ben à à aller
voter d'une certaine façon ils
arrivent cet événement qui est
quand même assez marquant dans
la campagne. Jason Kenney avait
appuyé dans la course à la
direction du parti un peu plus
d'un an. À l'époque ça ça avait
donné un élan à Earno Thill. Là
cette semaine sa présence
représentait pratiquement plus
un boulet pour le chef
conservateur. Euh pour deux
raisons. Aaron Toul a vanté
dans le passé la gestion de la
pandémie de Jason Kenney
premièrement et deuxièmement
euh il il pourrait encore une
fois euh être embêté sur sa
droite, encore une fois par le
parti de Maxime Bernier. C'est
comme si c'est difficile pour
de gagner dans cette
situation-là. Euh non seulement
on peut certains électeurs
peuvent penser ah si c'est un
conservateur qui gouverne,
est-ce qu'il va avoir des
politiques qui seront pas
suffisamment euh elle est
rigoureuse ou ou ou forte pour
contrôler la pandémie d'une
part et d'autres vont se dire
bon si c'est un conservateur
qui fait volte-face qui qui
ramène euh le passeport
vaccinal on en veut à ça aussi.
Donc Maxime Bernier a essayé de
capitaliser là-dessus. Donc
vous voyez c'est compliqué pour
sa stratégie à lui c'est de
pivoter critiquer Justin
Trudeau pour avoir déclenché
des élections en pleine
pandémie. Peut-être que Justin
Trudeau va porter une partie du
blâme chez certains électeurs
pour décision d'avoir déclenché
des des élections cet été mais
en je dirais quand même là que
en bout de ligne si on fait euh
si on fait l'équilibre dans
tout ça peut-être que Rennes va
avoir euh euh une journée plus
difficile et donc que ça va
avoir marqué la fin de la
campagne. Daniel Euh il y a
jour du vote, la façon dont la
pandémie marquera le jour du
vote, c'est difficile de le
déterminer pour l'instant. Je
pense que l'élection Canada a
préparé le terrain pour
s'assurer qu'il y aurait pas de
de de de de problèmes
similaires à ce que l'on a vu
par exemple à Terre-Neuve et La
Brador l'hiver dernier. Euh ce
qui est intéressant c'est que
les partis sur l'impact que la
pandémie a eu sur la la
campagne, on s'était posé la
question euh dans tous les
camps à peu près sur euh ce que
ça pourrait vouloir dire. Il y
avait des scénarios, est-ce
qu'on pourrait devoir mettre un
terme à la tournée nationale à
un moment donné est-ce qu'il
faudra limiter la campagne à
certains dans le cas des
conservateurs on avait même
préparé un studio ici dans la
région d'Ottawa euh forcé de
constater que ça s'est
relativement bien passé dans
l'ensemble et maintenant ce que
ça voudra dire la semaine
prochaine en terme de livraison
le jour où le bon pour la
sortie du vote là euh ça ça
risque de compliquer les choses
une province à l'autre ça
serait intéressant de voir si
en Alberta en Saskatchewan où
les mesures sanitaires ont été
resserrées au cours des
derniers jours est-ce que ça
pourrait avoir un impact euh et
puis bon je reviens sur ce que
ce que Madeleine disait
effectivement en en terme d'un
point de vue strictement
politique oui. Euh ça a un
impact sur la campagne des
conservateurs très très
certainement. Oui un un enjeu
euh un enjeu de brèche qui a
tenté d'être mis de l'avant par
certains acteurs politiques.
Euh on verra si ça sera ça a
été ou non à leur avantage. Je
rappelle à tout le monde qui
nous écoute hein. Là le le le
jour du choix final arrive pour
bon nombre d'entre vous
n'hésitez pas de vous tourner
sur euh nos plateform on a fait
des vérifications de faits tout
au long de la campagne. On a un
comparateur de programmes ou de
plateformes politiques. Il y a
aussi des analyses de nos euh
collègues qui sont disponibles
sur toutes nos plateformes que
vous êtes, vous pouvez aller
relire pour vous faire une tête
avant euh de faire euh de faire
votre choix euh dans l'urne.
Euh Madeleine et Daniel je vous
remercie infiniment de votre
participation à ce à cette
discussion en direct. On va
vous écouter d'ici à la soirée
électorale et lors de la soirée
électorale vos lumières seront
essentielles comme toujours.
Merci cher collègue. Au revoir.
Plaisir. À une prochaine. Et je
rappelle que cette soirée
électorale elle sera sur toutes
nos plateformes. C'est
important de le souligner parce
que c'est à plusieurs endroits,
des heures différentes,
dix-sept heures cinquante-cinq
sur RDI, Radio-Canada point CA,
sur Facebook et YouTube ou
Radio-Canada, information est
présent. Ensuite, à compter de
19 heures sur ICI Première,
Jean-Sébastien Bernacier qui va
piloter le tout euh à notre
antenne radio à l'échelle
nationale. Dix-neuf heures
trente sur ICI Télé et Tous
point TV plusieurs rendez-vous
pour vous, pour suivre cette
soirée électorale qui euh
s'annonce assez pimentée avec
beaucoup euh de surprises à
prévoir, avec aussi beaucoup de
suspense. On espère que vous
serez là avec nous pour qu'on
puisse vivre cette soirée
ensemble. Allez, je vous dis à
une prochaine. Prenez soin de
vous. Passez une belle fin de
semaine.